hey Vsauce Michael here and I am home
for the holidays I'm in my parents
basement using a different camera than
usual but you know what is always
different fingerprints the palms of our
hands and the soles of our feet are
weird they are covered with friction
ridges which act like the design of a
stamp that stamps everything you touch
plastic or patent prints are visible to
the naked eye but even with seemingly
clean hands on a seemingly clean surface
a fingerprint can be left a latent
fingerprint but what are those made of
well by the square millimeter that are
made out of this all of this stuff is
natural in fact a lot of it is produced
to keep your skin healthy waterproof
pliable but touch a surface enough and
the gunk can build up it's what causes
smudges on computer screens and mobile
devices
now given that protein contains 4
calories per gram fat contains 9
calories per gram and the surface area
of the iPhone 5 is 4400 square
millimeters completely licking clean a
smudgy iphone 5 screen is going to give
you about 2 calories if you were to lick
clean 245 smudgy iPhone 5s well that
would be the same as eating a Big Mac
but before you run off and get all of
your nutrition from smudgy phones you
should know that us humans need a bit
more variety than that I've always found
it interesting that cats and dogs can
grow up and live great lives eating the
exact same food every day well what
about us humans what can we eat every
day without ever changing it up and be
fine it turns out that there is one type
of food that you could eat every day for
the rest of your life and be fine
without ever having something different
if you follow at tweet sauce you already
know what it is the answer is
human breast milk whether your ridges
loop or arch or whirl is largely genetic
but the tiny minutiae of your prints
formed while you were developing inside
your mother it tells a story about the
very specific conditions around the
dividing cells that became your skin and
for that reason even identical twins who
pretty much share the exact same DNA
wind up with different fingerprints I
could clone you 100 times and every one
of those clones would have a unique set
of fingerprints your skin has two major
layers the epidermis on the outside and
the dermis which is below the basal
layer of your epidermis creates new skin
cells which migrate up towards the
outside world where they die and flatten
out forming the protective outermost
part of your skin the horny layer which
means that all day every day you are
covered with and showing off to the
entire world your horny layer these
outer cells are constantly shed away but
their arrangement stays the same because
their shape is determined by the shape
of the basal layer down below this is
why you can superficially in temporarily
sandpaper or cut off your fingerprints
but they'll still grow back the way they
were before but why do we have
fingerprints in the first place I mean
not all mammals have friction ridges is
this some sort of cruel joke the
universe made to make it more difficult
for us humans to get away with crimes
probably not the most likely answer is
to first of all it has been shown that
friction ridges allow us to sense subtle
textures 100 times better than if we
didn't have them and because
fingerprints loop an arch and swirl in
different directions all it takes is one
simple touch for us to detect a subtle
texture moving in any direction it's
also been shown that having free
chin ridges allows mammals like us
primates koalas the North American
Fisher to better climb and grasp wet
stuff even though no two fingerprints
are exactly the same the methods we have
for matching fingerprints aren't always
perfect there are plenty of different
ways to model fingerprints and each one
is calculated a different probability of
a false match but if you want to commit
a crime it's best to just avoid
fingerprints altogether how about hiring
someone with a dermatoglyphics can
conditions can cause the disappearance
of fingerprints but adermatoglyphia is a
genetic one that has no other side
effects but it's rare only for extended
families on earth are known to have the
condition but if you want to avoid
leaving fingerprints and can't find
somebody with adermatoglyphia don't
worry just find someone who hasn't gone
through puberty yet
sure kids might snot and slobber all
over stuff but they carry far less heavy
waxy oil on their skin and for this
reason the fingerprints of a child will
disappear evaporate much more quickly
than those of an adult a child's
fingerprints can evaporate in only a few
hours so use kids to commit your crimes
and as always thanks for watching
you